would you say yeah
that
women
are happy
in these days and like are women
happy
in relationships generally nowadays in
relationships in relationships to are
women happy
not in relationships no
you have to expand on that now yeah yeah
i mean i think i'm on my heart there
will be different
reasons
um and there's different factors that
come into play like first one being
because of past trauma okay um there
will still be they might still have
contact to their exes
um
they just their their feelings just
might be all over the place they haven't
healed and that will that will affect
that that's where a lot of the
confrontation will come from there will
there will be so much anger and
bitterness that they have gained from
their past traumas that they would just
exert onto their partner they would just
take it all out on them every little
thing every little thing is a trigger
for them have you have you seen that i
have seen that
yes but and then i think another factor
that comes into play
um wait hold on go on
if you've seen that you've seen it from
a friend
yes so if you've seen that from a friend
do you do you like i correct them yes do
you correct them yes male or female like
like what do you what what would be the
response from them like would it be in a
negative way or would it be in a
positive way i mean would they take your
take your advice and learn people don't
listen i think mel in this in this
situation when it comes to relationships
not all female people don't listen okay
i've seen from my male best friends he's
the number one culprit who just doesn't
listen no matter how many times i tell
him like okay you're not in a position
to be going in a relationship right now
you're not in a position to be talking
to this person right now that you're not
in a good state mentally you're not fine
he'll go in there anyways or go terrible
come back to me and i'm like well should
i listen to me same thing as a woman
like if i if if i see that
a woman is going to do something wrong
or if it's irrational i'll call her out
on it um
but then i'm gonna listen how did all
right so how do women react when you
call them out and stuff as a woman
um
my friends
they take it quite well i think but i
think that's because they're used to the
type of person that i am so they know
i'm quite like i'm not gonna take it i
think so if my my friends just know who
i am so if if i if if you're going to do
something like that in front of me
i'm not gonna
sit well wouldn't it so do they
have you got success from that do they
actually listen to your advice sometimes
but most of the time though okay because
the women that sorry the reason why i
asked if women are actually happy right
is because
in the uk
when it comes to divorce
64 of divorces are initiated by women
and in the usa
up to sometimes up to 80
of divorces are initiated by women wow
so
we're talking about marriage or
submission within marriage however it
seems like once women get into the
marriage
right
they are not happy enough to stay within
their marriage because the marriage is
being in the divorce sorry is being
initiated by women
majority of the time because they're
unhappy
and and
the um
and
women start saying no because men cheat
on the top 10 list
of the reasons why women are initiating
divorces
cheating comes in at number nine wow
i didn't know that wow
so the third so i'll try and get them
because i haven't got it okay
differences
um someone became the person that they
didn't think they were okay um
family members got too involved in the
relationship yeah um
i can't think of but there are multiple
but when it comes to cheating cheating
is not as high up on the list as you'd
expect as you would expect it to be i
think
women have been sold
a disney version of what our marriage is
yeah they've been sold via the social
medias
via even the films that we watch yeah
the comedies and the rom-coms and all
this kind of stuff and they think a
relationship is supposed to be like this
right when they get into the
relationship is that nothing like that
i think men are more realistic with what
a relationship is which is why are women
actually happy so why are women the ones
initiating the divorces um
my
i don't know what my answers to it is
because i don't know i
those those some of those things seem
really interesting to me i think
the whole family stuff have you been in
a relationship yes i think so i know
you're young right
so in that relationship that you were in
did you break it off did he break it off
he
you sure yeah you didn't seem too shy
are you sure yeah i'm sure yes okay
so
if you have friends right
who are girls and they've been in
relationships
if you were to ask them or because
you've been around your friends right
you know
who's in
nine times out of ten who's going to
break it up would you say it's more
women breaking up with men than it is
men breaking out women
and my friends no
it's the men breaking
from what i've seen it's more men
here's the question though was those
girls actually in relationships
and and i think that's a great question
that's a great question we're not
talking about this
that is what we shed light on because
situations
a lot of women
think they are in relationships but
they're not they're not ready for that
in relationships right and so i mean
just the other day um i did a review
i was talking about lonnie good
right
and lani was on this other show
and she was saying that she was she used
to date footballers she to date rappers
and then i think mediocre tutorial
reviews was reviewing it and he was like
nah you never used to have sex with him
but you weren't in relationships with
him
because you think that having sex
consistently with a man equals a
relationship wow and so
a man who is going to claim you because
the bottom line is talk about this would
that man claim you you're claiming him
but is he claiming you i i've met lonnie
in it i can't talk about this one so
okay i'm not i'm just saying like you
know what it is i think the point is
valid though it is
like
there's there's some girls out here that
they live in our mind where they think
they're in this situation but it's not
really there was one thing that i saw in
tik tok um
yeah some guy was talking about oh men
are happy to waste your time they will
gladly
drag out talking stage for six eight ten
months two years i saw a girl saying
yesterday she ended the two-year talking
stage men will gladly drag it out they
won't put a title on it but what kind of
men though you understand there's men
that don't have no they have to bear
time on our hands and they will do that
but the men
they have time on our hands
we ain't got time for that we've got
money to make you understand so
but the thing is on the flip side women
will happily stay with a man
who they knows wasting their time trying
to change him there you go
they go they will happily stay with him
knowing that
no but you know what he can be this and
he can be her potential
i've seen girls i've seen girls complain
about
certain man i don't want to say no name
but i want to say i've seen girls that
say oh my ex is this my axe is that rare
tear
then you're telling me
you've let my man into your yard
man's break down you're all there caring
for him same guy in your car
and the same guy that he was complaining
about us whoa
you hugging him up comforting him that's
what i'm saying man you need to know
what you want man for real because
there's men out here that we we know we
know ourselves i don't have time for
that man now time to
i don't mind you see with time time is
money time is valuable
i use my time actually you're saying
you've never wasted a woman's time
before me
i don't waste a woman's time you know
what it is listen as a man i believe
we've ordered the day i'm the day we've
all done we've all done that bro listen
like life is life i'm 21 years of age
come on now but i'm the day
i'm using my time even though if i'm
even though if i'm wasting time i know
i'm using my time behind that
but i i know my time is valuable
but yeah when a when a man
[Laughter]
when a man
steps to you as a woman right and
you know
or you you're attracted to him
within what time frame
do you know or not know
you should know that he's going to be a
time waster
my max is two months max
max but before then i think i normally
tell but if it's if we're still in a
talking stage with two months in you're
done
you're done
you're done so so the talking stage can
last two months maximum is that dates
and everything all of that yeah yeah
okay that's the maximum for me
so are you now are you actively looking
to get into a relationship right now no
i'd be open to if it happens are you
actively looking to get into a
relationship right now no but if it
finds me then cool yeah you know and
that's because of what your age because
it's because of
it's not because of my a actually it's
just because
people are not serious
i agree i don't think people are serious
are you serious am i serious yeah it
sounds like deflecting yeah
i'm just asking bro
whoops accountability is a thing
i'm serious
when opportunity is
presented what you don't say this
earlier a man a man will be a feminine
man will be masculine for the right one
it sounded like that you know it's cool
all right right now
my
as a man
my main purpose
is my career that's my thing right you
understand
second okay cool if a woman comes in my
life
my wife she's got she takes all the
boxes then cool but my main purpose is
that
you know what i'm saying if it finds me
it finds people i'm not looking for that
there's people that
i know people that look i know there's
people that look for that
and
because i look at because i'm looking
for that so hard it it paths away from
the main purpose in life and they forget
what they want to do yeah i'm i'm on
that i'm sorry but like i said if it
comes to me then cool